Yo tout le monde , c'est SQUEEZIE !!
Ca vous a manqué ?
Aujourd'hui on est sur Don't Take This Risk ( Ne prenez pas ce risque)
C'est un jeu qui traitre d'un sujet très sensible, qui est le suicide
En gros, on va recevoir l'appel de quelqu'un qui voulait joindre la hotline suicide , donc un numéro d'assistance
Pour les personnes qui pensent au suicide, il y en a tous les jours, c'est dramatique d'en arriver là
Et peut-être que certains d'entre vous même sont passés par là et c'est totalement horrible.
Je trouve que personne devrait nous pousser à bout , au point d'avoir envie de mettre fin a ses jours.
Sauf que nous, dans le jeu, nous sommes une fille et on est pas du tout la hotline que la personne voulait joindre.
Donc, on va lui dire, bah appelle le bon numéro.
On va raccrocher et là on va se dire, putain de merde, le gars voulait quand même joindre le numéro d'assistance suicide, il va peut-être faire une connerie.
Voilà, tout commence de là, heeuuuu...
C'est parti !!
Donc mon téléphone vibre. Je réponds.
Bonjour !
Nan, tu as le mauvais numéro.
Pas de soucis, pas de soucis.
Nan, reste en ligne, laisse moi te donner le bon numéro...
Wait, tu vas pas te blesser....
OK ! Je prends le premier !!
J'ai très peu de temps!
Mais nan mais c'est pas grave mec.. T'as pas à avoir honte, laisse moi t'aider.
Nan, nan NAN !
Nan, reste et parle..
Heeuuu..
Promets moi que tu demanderas de l'aide !
Putain, on a moins d'une seconde pour répondre!
J'ai dis que ça me rendrais triste s'il se blessait.
Mais, même ça me fais chier que quelqu'un se blesse même si je ne le connais pas.
Et ben les gens autour de toi ne savent pas à coté de quoi ils passent, c'est tout !
All people... NAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAN !!!! j'ai pas eu le temps de répondre !
Merde !! Merde!! Merde!! Merde !!
Je le rappelle.
Ah, naaaaan ...
Bon je lui envoie un SMS.
Il a bu
Et pris des pillules.
Naan !
Je lui dis d'aller à l'hôpital.
Il ne veut pas...
Mais, il me dit, qu'il pense que les infirmières sont sexy
(rires)
Bah, va à l'hôpital putain !
Il dit qu'il veut mourrir.
"Pourquoi tu veux te tuer ?" Putain pourquoi j'ai dis ça ?
J'ai pas eu le temps de lire l'autre.
"Are you okay ?"
Aller dit quelque chose !
Désolé, j'ai eu un Black Out.
(rires) Putain..
Raconte moi, ce qu'il se passe à propos de ta maison
c'est un bel endroit
Est-ce que tu est déjà allé en France ?
Ah, bah oui !!
Il est en France ?
Non.
Ah, putain on aurait pu aller le voir.
Je peux te dire quels sont les meilleurs restaurants
(rires)
Oh, putain, il me dit qu'il n'arrive plus a respirer et que je dois l'aider
Dis moi où t'es.
Aide moi.
Mais donne moi ton adresse !
J'arrive pas à respirer
Donne moi ton adresse !
Attends, je peux l'appeller ? Je l'appelle.
(sonnerie)
Nan !! Il peut pas respirer pourquoi je l'appelle ? Il va pas pouvoir me parler !
(décroche)
( bruits d'étouffement )
( Musique)
Woooaaaw !!!
Merde à quel moment j'ai déconné ?
Bon déjà quand j'ai pas eu le temps de répondre
et qu'il a raccroché..
Donc là il s'est étouffé..
Merde !
Bon..
Ba ok hein..
Bon deuxième essai, deuxième essai !
J'vais lui dire.. euh.. j'vais rester sur "non tu as pris le mauvais truc"
C'est bien ça.
Ok, il va raccrocher et cette fois je vais lui dire..
"Eh je rigole, ne raccroche pas."
Eh mais je suis trop con
Je suis pas la suicide hot-line
Pourquoi je fais semblant d'être la suicide hotline ?
Mais aie confiance en toi un petit peu là !
C'est pas parce que t'as pas le corps de Tibo Inshape
Que tu peux pas avoir confiance en toi..
Et j'ai un cœur, ok ?
Roo putain..
Mais si..
Mais bien sûr que si !
Tout le monde peut tomber amoureux et faire tomber amoureux quelqu'un
(hésitation)
J'me suis mal exprimé !
Je bosserai vraiment jamais pour une hot-line !
Euh..
Je t'aime !
Voilà, je lui ai dit "je t'aime", j'ai craqué..
Roo putain..
OK ! Ok..
On va.. Pour sauver une vie on va faire ça !
Putain il est désespéré de ouf !
Et il est contradictoire
Ya deux secondes, il me disait que personne ne pourrait jamais l'aimer
Et là, j'lui dit "je t'aime" et il part en vrille.
Bin j'ai pas trop le choix..
Euh ok vas-y..
J'sais très que si je dis non il va se re-étouffer
donc euh..
(bruits de pas)
(tocs à la porte)
(grincements)
Putain mais il est carrément bg, d'où personne peut t'aimer ?
Ok, il a bougé pour t'envelopper dans ses bras et il t'a mis contre son truc euh..
"Je le pousse !"
Il s'enflamme un peu là.
Nan nan, y a pas de soucis,
je veux de toi mais ça va un peu vite là.
Mais nan !
(grincements)
(porte qui claque)
(musique)
Putain mais heureusement que j'ai pas fait ça à chaque râteau hein !
Ce qui est bien, c'est qu'on peut revenir sur nos choix
donc on va voir si je l'avais pas poussé
ce qu'il se serait passé.
Hop, je lui fait un câlin.
(battements de cœur)
Non.. (rire gêné)
Amène une couverture ouais.
euh..
I don't want you to kill yourself
Franchement, j'vais lui dire la vérité, j'vais dire "J'veux juste pas que tu te tues en fait"
Aaah !
C'est glauque là ce qu'il se passe là quand même !
Je veux bien apporter de l'aide au gens mais là..
C'est chaud quand même !
Là c'est plus moi qui ai besoin d'aide que lui.
Putain faire un choix là vite.
"Pourquoi pas?"
"Parce tu es très beau"
Bah je vais dire "pourquoi pas?"
Et alors ?
J'espère bien mec !
Alors est ce que tu peux faire quelque chose pour moi ?
Euh..
"Promets moi que tu te battras pour vivre chaque jour"
C'est bien ça !
Putain il me répète que le temps que je serais là y a pas de soucis
mais JE VEUX PAS ETRE LA !!
Putain.
Ok, on se voit demain.
Pas le premier soir, mon ami.
Je vais rest- Je vais pas dormir chez toi alors qu'on vient de se connaître.
Soit je lui dis "ouais mais je le sens pas de rester ce soir"
soit je lui dis "ok mais ne me fais rien de bizarre"
mais il va nous trucider la gueule quand on dormira..
Bon vas y, ok, on reste et on lui dit de rien nous faire de bizarre.
Oh putain..
En plus, il est lourd.
On peut dormir maintenant ?
J'aimerais dormir.
(le mec chante une chanson d'amour)
Deuxième fin sur neuf : "rester avec moi pour l'éternité"
Oh c'est glaauuque !
Le mec, il a dû nous ligoter et on est son prisonnier à vie quoi..
Ok, on va revenir en arrière !
J'vais lui dire que je veux pas rester
et en proposition, je peux soit dire "ok on reste"
soit dire "on se voit demain"
Aller on se voit demain.
(grincements, porte qui claque)
Raa putain !
Il faut qu'il arrête de se tirer une balle dans la tête.
Ok, bon!
Alors on va tout reprendre du début !
Ok, je lui dit de rester en ligne et que j'vais lui filer le bon numéro.
Promets moi que tu auras de l'aide
"Je n'ai pas besoin d'aide."
"Ça me rendrait triste si tu te blesses"
Ok, il dit la même chose que tout à l'heure.
Donc je lui ai dit d'appeler la hotline parce que, eux, ils s'en foutent pas.
Il m'a dit "ok"
Oh putain il faut qu'il appelle, le con, faut qu'il appelle !
Bon je l'appelle !
En fait il faut que je m'assure qu'il ait bien appeler la hotline.
Je suis sûr qu'il y a une happy ending mais c'est dur d'y arriver
(raccroche)
Ok on va le voir !
(tocs à la porte)
(grincements)
Ok, on est venu
Il faut surtout pas le pousser sinon il se tire une balle direct !
Ok, on va lui dire d'appeler la suicide hotline.
Ouais c'est un peu pour ça ouais.
Euh...
"Je sais pas comment t'aider, eux, ils savent"
Voilà.
"Nan je te crois pas."
Tu vas te tuer.
"Tu as bien fait de ne pas me croire"
(bruits de pas)
(cri)
"Il a mis sa bouche contre la tienne, il a fait un gros bisou."
Ok, je le frappe !
(Claque)
(rire du mec)
Je vais pas te mentir un peu.
Ok, soit je lui mets un coup de tête soit je lui prends sa tête et je l'explose contre le lit.
Je vais plutôt faire ça comme ça il a bien mal
et je me barre !
Soit j'appelle la police
Soit je le regarde reprendre ses esprits.
Nan j'appelle la police.
Il est trop dangereux.
C'est- c'est un peu les deux.
Roo putain.
Nan je vais pas t'empêcher de te suicider pour te tuer moi-même.
Ça n'a pas de sens.
(rire)
Soit je l'embrasse soit je lui explose la tête contre le mur.
Ok, je lui met la tête contre le mur pour qu'il s'évanouisse !
(CLAC!)
Oh merde j'ai frappé trop fort
Il saigne énormément, il bouge plus.
Soit je check son pouls, soit je pars en courant.
Bon ba je pars en courant.
Il est mort ?
(musique)
Haan..
Oh j'l'ai buté..
Putaiiiin !
Attends on part d'un mec qui se gourre de numéro
je vais pour l'aider et au final je vais un homicide involontaire
c'est moi qui- et c'est moi qui prends cher.
Enfin il est quand même mort dans le- au final j'ai quand foiré mon objectif.
(BIP)
Oh putain ! Bon les gens j'ai regardé
En fait, y a neuf fins possibles, y en a une seule où c'est quand tu lui dit pas que tu l'aimes, où il s'étouffe
c'est la première partie de la vidéo finalement
et les huit autres, c'est à partir du moment où tu lui dit que tu l'aimes
Et il n'y a pas de happy ending.
et que tu-tu vas chez lui
c'est là où il y a huit fins possibles quoi.
Soit en gros tu deviens sa prisonnière
soit tu acceptes de passer la fin de ta vie avec lui
mais ça c'est un peu chelou
soit tu le pousses et tu le tues sans faire exprès, soit elle-il le bute, soit il se tire une balle dans la tête parce qu'il est frustré
'Fin du coup y a pas de happy ending tout simplement parce que c'est putain de psychopathe
c'est pas juste un mec qui veut se suicider, qui est en détresse, c'est un psy-cho-pathe !
Je pensais que ça allait être quelqu'un en détresse comme il y en a partout dans le monde
et c'est hyper triste, je pensais qu'on allait se mettre à la place de quelqu'un qui reçoit un appel vraiment
de ces gens-là en détresse qui existent et qui sont pas des psycopathes.
Et ba hésitez pas à aimer si l'expérience vous a plu
J'ai trouvé ça très oppressant, très angoissant
C'est entre le "putain j'ai envie de l'aider ce mec là, quand même sa vie c'est un enfer,
il est devenu psychopathe peut être parce qu'il a vécu des trucs horribles aussi.
Mais est ce moi je suis prêt à me sacrifier pour lui alors que je le connais même pas.
Putain c'est assez- c'est très psychologique comme jeu, j'aime beaucoup !
Jusqu'où serions nous capable d'aller pour sauver un inconnu ?
C'est ça finalement la morale du jeu.
Bon en tout cas j'espère que ça vous a plu, c'est un peu différent de ce qu'on fait d'habitude mais ça fait du bien.
A bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo.
Merci d'avoir regardé,
Ciao tout le monde
Peace !